[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est un peu la crémaillère
de la combattante 60 mètres de long 10 m
de large pour 700 tonnes d'acier tous
les 30 ans la combattante fait peau
neuve alors forcément elle était
attendue
accueilli avec les honneurs à fort de
france son commandant n'en est pas peu
fier il a beaucoup de capacités de mise
en oeuvre de moyens de détection et
d'intervention sur d'autres d'autres
bâtiments
il a aussi une capacité de pour mieux
aller en aide à une population qui
serait sinistrés après une catastrophe
naturelle
c'est un bateau qui est assez polyvalent
pour assurer ses missions la combattante
et dotées d'équipements à la pointe de
la technologie radar caméra de nuit hier
thierry et même un moteur hybride
ce patrouilleur doit pouvoir intervenir
en quelques minutes avec ses deux
embarcations légères
on a un gros bras de levier qui va
mettre le zodiac à l'eau
on a un plongeur de bord à l'intérieur
on a un pied dans marca sion est
mécanicien et ils vont partir en inter
pour récupérer le maillot vert c'est
exactement le même bateau sauf que
celui-là est spécialisé pour les
internes arcop ce donc que là on va
avoir tous nos gars qui vont monter
intérieur on peut gré et une
mitrailleuse à l'avant on ouvre la route
derrière le bateau part et par en un
terreau direct des interventions rapides
et reese important un confort de vie
avec sa cuisine flambant neuve elle
comblera une mission primordiale car
apparemment dans l'armée c'est chez les
marins que l'on mange le mieux c'est
très important pour le moral de
l'équipage parce que les missions
peuvent être très longs vite devenir
très bon aussi et par rapport à l'état
de la mer aussi
il ya des fois où on est
ça bouge un peu où on n'est pas
forcément très bien et le fait de bien
manger ça ça redonne un peu c'est après
les cyclones yerma et maria que la
décision était prise de changer de
patrouilleurs la combattante dernière
génération permet aux 24 marins
d'accomplir leur mission dans les
meilleures conditions
il va apporter des capacités de
patrouille des capacités d'action en mer
pour lutter contre les trafics de
stupéfiants pour venir en aide à des
populations dans des îles impacté par
des phénomènes cycloniques ou seesmic et
qui va également mener des missions de
sauvetage en mer ou de lutte contre les
pollutions marines d'ailleurs dès sa
première mission la combattante est venu
en renfort lors du crash d'un avion de
tourisme près de la dominique la
première intervention du monde carrière